everyone to our online training program
I want to give you today a brief
overview of what we plan to do and
hopefully we can have a short discussion
at the end of this hear how you decided
to join the program and participate we
really want to get to know you because a
big part of this program is go together
and not just us delivering these online
lectures so first of all the goal of
this program is to really talk about
bioinformatics but in the context of
biological research so the field of
bioinformatics has evolved and today
faces a challenge of big and complex
data that is readily available right we
all know about ncbi and other
repositories that made a lot of this
data but getting something useful out of
that data is a lot of times a challenge
and so this Onix logic program bring
together biologists and by limitations
who work together and apply analysis
methods to next-generation sequencing
data with an emphasis on the logical
connection between the sequencing data
the experimental design and the
meaningful utilization of advanced
analytical methods to address biological
questions related to basic research
biotechnology applications and human
health and I think it's very important
to understand the logical connection
between experiment design sequencing
methodologies and analytical methods
because at the center of all of these
steps there are people and these people
have to speak a common language and so
that's what the program is focused on is
developing that language that connects
dots between the lab where the
biologists need to know and what ways to
improve the data collection and in what
ways the data is needed what more data
is needed to enter a research question
in a comprehensive and reliable way you
know they need to understand how the
bioinformaticians will use this data to
test the hypothesis
maybe train a new machine learning model
with this data and balance magicians
also has to integrate multiple data sets
so it's important to understand what
considerations go into their ability to
take data that is normalized that is
ready to be implied and that could be
integrated and at the end of the day the
people that work with this data that
makes the decisions based on this data
also need to be aware of that whole
process where the data originated from
how it was analyzed and how it could be
trusted where to expect some batch
effects or overfitting or even lack of
representation and so that's why we can
want to talk about biology as data but
when we talk about data science or
bioinformatics it could be uncomfortable
or even a little bit easy for people
that do not have the necessary
mathematical computational statistical
background to utilize these design
methods and so what we wanted to do is
simplify the tools and the project
enough so that anyone without any coding
experience without any mathematical
background that is not ready to maybe
invest the time to learn the coding and
to learn how to solve complex
mathematical problems so to be able to
utilize the methods to interesting
projects the projects that are
interesting to you in terms of research
and maybe application and so that we can
get that process started right so it's
an opportunity to kind of come together
focus on specific challenges I'm trying
to do this independently for some
hands-on exercises that could accelerate
the process so over the past several
years our team has conducted a number of
different programs at university
campuses around the world we have been
working extensively with faculty
researchers and students and as a result
of these different experiences what we
have done is we have developed these
online training resources so essentially
we're talking about
six online modules these modules are
going to be available throughout this
program for all of you to supplement
these online meetings these include an
introduction to bioinformatics but a
little bit about the different ways
bioinformatics has addressed specific
challenges the different methodologies
and different exciting projects that we
will be covering in this program and
that are covered in part on the website
genomics and so genomic data like single
nucleotide variation and abundance of
mutation in different regions and etc
transcripts genic and either form
expression and how Jim and Isaac form
expressions could be studied using
various methods epigenetic variation
like histone modification and DNA
methylation metagenomics which includes
the study of amplifying 60th and 18s
ribosomal RNA as well as full 16s
metagenomic and an introduction to
machine learning so as you can see a lot
of these data types are next hour based
on next-generation sequencing so that is
why the title of our program is
bioinformatics but in the context of
next-generation sequencing and utilizing
different analytical approaches
including machine learning approaches to
the study of the data with a focus on
Biological discovery so for the next
three months you will have access to all
of our online training resources
sorry somebody appear to annotate
you
okay and at the same time what you will
find is that our team will be available
to to assist you with any questions or
technical challenges that you may face
so the way that these materials are
structured is something that we will go
over everybody now has registration and
accounts on our educational website and
on that account you and our program
managers will be able to see all of the
data about your progress so you we will
you and us we will see how much progress
you're making with online resources the
projects the practical assignments that
we have and we will try and use this
data so that we can best assist you to
move forward and the project
so first of all I hope that all of you
have an email from Sahil that will get
you to this stage to the educational
website and let me switch over from the
presentation to the website just to kind
of show you how to navigate those
resources so on the
you
so all of you have an email that has
your account information that you will
find - you will find that you will be
able to log in to the website and on the
website you will find resources here on
top now throughout the program you will
be able to access all of our paid
materials for free that includes some of
the paid projects and some of the paid
courses so if you are having trouble
getting access to any of those make sure
that you are
make sure that you are talking to the
heel which is going to be right here in
this chat box that you will be able to
ask for the discount codes or ask for
any other clarifications so now as you
can see my screen this is the home page
and if you are logged in you will be
able to see your profile right here now
please if you can go into your profile
and make sure that all the information
there is up to date and I will show you
a little bit what we will be seeing from
the interactions throughout this program
if you scroll all the way down we will
see this link under organizations for
bioinformatics
sorry
okay I see that
I want to mass here and let me know if
you have trouble hearing what I'm saying
I'm try and speak up louder
or like you said we will have on a
recorded version of this
so going back to the website this page
is dedicated to our program so you will
see here upcoming events so right now
this is the event that we are off on and
you can see all of the upcoming events
and their dates and their time and some
of the things that we will cover on that
event now you do not have to register
individually to all of these events but
it would be helpful for us to know who
is going to event so that we can prepare
the right materials and send them out to
you just in case we will also post
information relevant to this to the
upcoming session right here on the stage
for example I am just going to ask you
to fill out
before that will give us a little bit
more information about your educational
and research background so now if you
click on this form you will see that
again we know that we have some of this
information just so that the information
is consistent for everybody we want to
make sure that you are able to fill out
your email some of your educational
backgrounds etc now you will see that
some of this information will be
available on this stage that I'm showing
right here but you will also be getting
emails from city'll and please make sure
that the Millstone go into your junk
folder you also will be getting various
notifications from the different things
that you do practically so just look out
for those emails with T - bio info
domain name what you will also see here
is we have a forum on the forum you're
welcome to ask any questions or anything
that you would like us to discuss and we
will be posting here the recorded
sessions for these sessions that we hold
online you can also go to the curriculum
tab and in the curriculum tab you can
see what we are trying to cover in each
session in more of a timeline format
anything we'll see here at the bottom
how to reach us off and asking questions
or as for any materials that were shaker
now you will also see that you will have
the members page and we hope that you
will also find the opportunity to
connect so that you can work on projects
together or potentially answering
questions in that format as well
so this is a little bit about the page
dedicated to the learning program the
omelets logic online training program
you will also find courses over here and
these courses are going to be something
that you will supplement the materials
that we go over through the sessions in
person like this now I also want to talk
a little bit about your profile so this
is my profile and you can see here that
you will have this section right here
with points that shows how much you how
much progress you are making now our
Google and we hope for all of you to get
to 10,000 points through the course of
the next three months what does the
10,000 points consist of you will see
that your courses under projects other
points and progress all of this
information is going to be recorded so
you can see that after you complete a
course after you complete or start a
course and after you complete any quiz
for any assignment you will get points
but also you get points for running
pipeline and we'll talk a little bit
about running pipelines in the in the
next few minutes so here for progress
you can see example of points for
passing a course or for running
pipelines
raesha
okay so going back to the presentation I
just want to show a little bit how the
content is organized so each one of the
online modules is going to be an online
learning experience where you will see
short sections so all of these sections
have an estimated time to complete so
please take a look at some of those
you'll also be able to download PDF
versions of these materials if you want
to look at them offline and what we will
see is that a lot of the theoretical
materials are supported by practical
exercises the practical exercises will
take you from the educational site to
our aunt political platform called
server that T - bio - info so it's the
same platform but this is the analytical
practical component we will see that
each section under the next generation
sequencing type of data is organized in
a very similar way you always have the
inputs which are here on top we have
some pre-loaded genomes on here and
different file formats that you can use
and we will provide you with some
initial data sets that you can work for
also at the bottom you will see that
each set of your analytical pipeline
will be annotated with informative
pop-ups and reference publications that
you can read more about the methods that
we are using now this is the server that
T - bio info interface and you should
have gotten an email with your account
for this as well so let me quickly
switch over
and once you log in you will be able to
see that here you also have your profile
with your email address and with some
information about you so after you
receive that email you can click on
login and here you will see your email
is your username and this is your
password and you can click on remember
me so that you will see your robot
now here under each section
are you seeing yeah just making sure
that you can see
okay you see my screen
okay so here you will see that each
section is divided into these
subsections and you have a number of
applications for next generation
sequencing data so we will focus on some
of these sections right here as well as
some of the sections under data money
utilities and some of the sections under
data Association Association which will
touch upon now you will see here as well
as a chat box again with Cisco and any
trouble you have logging in or accessing
anything we can always put it right here
and we will hope to address any
questions in a very timely way like I
said each section works in a very
similar way so we will talk more about
this next time and you can also look at
some videos that we will send you after
this session on how to utilize the
platform but essentially what you will
do every time is you will select some
type of a data format for example an
organism so genome that you would like
to align the sequence to and here you be
able to upload file now in this program
we will provide you with datasets that
you will use either with s-video links
directly to fast view files that are
already uploaded on the server or whole
collections of data that will come in a
single file and we'll go over how to
technically do this in the future but
for example if I have file that's called
yielded back that's cute now I will be
able to use this sound is going
thank you okay so now you can see that
the platform recognizes that the file
has been uploaded so if I need to use
groups now I can build my pipeline so
here you will have darker color buttons
that represent the selection that you
can make with the type of data that you
uploaded and then once you select any
kind of a method you'll be able to read
about that method and oftentimes go to
the publication relevance and you can
see the connection between the steps
that you're making and all of these are
also color-coded helping you to
understand the logic of the inputs the
outputs and what to expect when you have
completed your pipeline so we're not
going to really do anything with this
right the second and we will try to move
on into the practical aspects of the
platform after we complete our next
session but once you completed your
pipeline you save it
you
and you can run your Python do not
forget to run your pipeline because
otherwise it will be just prepared so
you can see under my pipeline this one
is prepared if I go back into the
pipeline I can see what I've prepared
and I can run and if I don't run it it
will just say prepare we will also be
using some demo pipelines that will talk
a little bit more in our next session
you
okay so the platform is really built to
allow this kind of an interactive way to
launch algorithms and before them on
large data without having to rely on the
computational resources that you have
available in front of you so it does not
use any of your hard drive it does not
use any of your RAM on the computer this
is all cloud-based and all the files are
already pre-loaded and once we are ready
to work on an independent project we'll
help you get those files in there so
that you can practice and work with them
now the other aspect is that we will
learn how to look at data and understand
what this data means so we will try and
link that data that we got as an output
from the pipelines with us how to
analyze and get some meanings and
information that we can answer questions
about some biological processes we will
try to link that primarily with
phenotypes so how to connect next
generations sequence data with some
observed phenotype at different levels
the trainers in the program will have
the opportunity to address different
aspects of the projects and the topics
that we are going to be covered so I
also already mentioned to you the heel
is going to be primarily responsible for
technical support and making sure that
you have all the files all of the
recordings who are account information
and anything else that is needed
justin is heading up our educational
materialist developments and he is going
to be talking about some of the
biological background of the project
that we are setting and will help answer
any questions on the biology perspective
for these projects Julia is currently
PhD students that is going to help
understand some of the methods that we
will utilize to analyze the process next
generation sequencing and Mohit is going
to be assisting in in India primarily
with the protonation there but also he
is a computational biologist himself and
so possibly he will help address some of
the computational and machine learning
methods that we will discuss throughout
this program
now the program is not only our time by
tech team but we also rely on
consultants and advisors from our
partners at the Talgo bioinformatics
research center which is a research
center based in Israel at University of
Haifa and the people at that Center are
the primary developers of the methods
and the platform itself and they will
help us address any technical challenges
for sometimes explain the complex
bioinformatics approaches that we will
be utilizing
now the idea of the program is that we
will look at several publications and
these publications typically include
their experimental data so we will rely
on publications that have
next-generation sequencing data and it
will utilize some methods and these
methods have been published and digested
and applied to address a specific
challenge but we will try to link those
two by reading that publication and we
will use that publication to also ask
you several questions to make sure that
we're all in the same page and we
understand correctly lion specific
methods were used and why the data set
how the data set was analyzed and what
were the results and how to understand
those results but as a result of this
process we will see that there's a
connection between data and methods and
by trying other data analysis methods
and other data that is similar to what
we studied we will be able to develop a
novel and independent project so a
project that could be called
independently yours and you are welcome
to work in teams or together or even
just to observe and learn how these
similar projects were already developed
so we will provide you with a starting
point with many different types of
projects that we have prepared and you
can start with it's up to you which one
you pick and we will kind of spend a
little bit more time on several of these
but just to give you an idea of what
types projects we have prepared for this
program we have some analysis at the
genomic analysis of human T cell
differentiation in asthma patients or
Marvin precision treatment of breast
cancer for viral mutation length a study
using ultra deep syrup sequencing or
polio agriculture and environmental
programs projects related to toxic
resistance and time packages changing
the newest
in cancer with tumor associated
macrophages and we look at microbiome
biomarkers from the American gut
microbiome project whole transcriptome
profiling of cancer tumors in Mouse PE X
model deregulation of sub cellular
network and sensor patients based on
cancer Atlas genome at TCGA intent
yelling biologics production and so sf9
cell lines and rats the virus
contamination published by the FDA crop
drought stress and resistance in potato
different crops potato crops complex
gene regulation in neurodegenerative
diseases so this is going to talk about
the increment syndrome and by the way
for those of you that are interested in
neurodegenerative diseases we are
looking at an upcoming conference in
Louisiana where at the annual biomass
conference we will have an expert on
Engelmann syndrome doctor comes run from
University of Haifa and Julia or not who
is going to be presenting doing a
hands-on workshop if you're willing to
travel to Baton Rouge to OSU and
participate in that hands-on project
you've invited and you can ascend that
for free and also join the session that
dr. Carson will lead on a balloon
syndrome on April 6th so if you're
interested to complete us know and we'll
help but coordinate the times so please
you can reach out to see you about that
I will talk about Ebola deadly mutations
study of the West African epidemic in
2013 2016 obviously now it's recurrence
it's important to understand how those
Ebola strains involved and you will be
able to develop your own project as well
so if you are interested in a specific
data set we are not going to jump to
that right at the beginning because we
believe that
preparing for the project and planning
your analysis
it is critical for the success so all
these projects are based on publications
like I said and when we look at them we
extract the data and we help build those
connections between how the data was
prepared where it was taken from how to
analyze it and then what conclusions
could be made and we'll try quite a
number of different methods to see the
ways that those could be used
effectively and also understand why some
approaches are not going to be very
effective that are those that have
completed our program have presented
individual posters or team posters on
the project doesn't support all of us of
the primary background or faculty and
PhD postdocs so you know this could be a
department seminar this could be
participation some kind of a conference
this could be used in application to
your own data so if that is an outcome
that is interesting to use and we are
interested to help you get there as much
as possible but it will require some
coordination so the sooner you reach out
to us about it the better we can help
you put the valta
as I mentioned we will be monitoring a
lot of the activity on the educational
website on the server platform where you
will run the analysis to try and collect
some data also using quizzes and surveys
to Atlantica like they are on
participation we are really trying to
develop this program into a very high
quality program that we can speak about
our achievements and not just the
process
so we're trying to make sure that
everybody reaches a certain level of
competency when we say that they have
successfully completed this program we
will be trying to reach out to you
individually or through our
representatives to make sure that
everybody is making good progress in a
timely way obviously if you're
interested at the end you will be able
to get a certificate of completion on
this three-month online training program
if you are a faculty member and you are
considering to utilize some of these
research resources getting your
education in the training that you
conduct at your university please let us
know we have some explanation about how
this whole program works on this link on
this website so you can look at look at
this stage but so I'll just show you
real quick how you can learn more about
these resources and also if you are
interested in that but you can
definitely reach out to suggestion
Justin will be able to explain how the
program works and how we are using this
program in several universities today
including Georgetown University
University of Grambling State University
LSU and some of the Louisiana
universities University of Haifa and
others so you can read a little bit more
about this and basically what I've told
you today about the online resources
about these sessions and hackathons we
conduct and some of the types of
workshops that we have prepared for all
of this comes in a package that you
could implement at your university if
you were willing and interested to do so
with our supporters
what are we going to cover in this
program so in this program we will
review how the world of next-generation
sequencing has changed the way we can
study molecular and cell processes from
the way data is stored in the DNA to the
way that it is controlled in epigenetic
using different epigenetic variation and
how it gets transcribed and we can study
that with gene expression and then we
can also do a lot of things with
available datasets that we have online
and different repositories and so we can
mine those big datasets to try and
understand some aspect of that biology
and then learn how to validate those
findings using other datasets and we'll
talk a little bit more about how to
structure a bioinformatics analysis
project and how to present it and how to
talk about these different analysis
methods that we are going to utilize to
make sure that they were fine-tuned to
really address the problem that we are
trying to solve so now what I want to do
is just talk a little bit about previous
programs that we ran and how this might
be useful to two huge different types of
people that are participating this
program so in the past when we conducted
these programs we saw that the majority
of the people self supplied from the
program if they attended most of the
online sessions and not watch them
independently with recordings because in
the online session you can ask questions
we can have a discussion we can dive
deeper into some aspects of what we're
talking about and all of that is more
intelligent if you let us know how it's
interesting to you or what is it that
you find most challenging so having that
dial
is very important now obviously during
the session we can do that
but the sessions are only one hour long
so having that information in advance is
going to be very helpful to us I also
think that most of the people that we
worked with in the past benefited from
the program if they had some free time
to go through the online materials these
materials do not require too much time
some of them could take an hour now and
a half some of them take a little bit
longer to complete but if you complete
some of them and you have some technical
challenges then we would be more
prepared to address those in the
sessions if you don't do any of the
online materials and you just jump to
the practical things we do in the online
sessions you might lose out on some of
that information so that's a little bit
about the program about our team about
what we're trying to do and now we have
some time and I would like to start by
letting see you who is going to be the
primary coordinator for the program say
a few words about his background and and
kind of how he is going to be involved
in this program and then after sahil's
justin will say a couple words about the
educational aspect and how as biologists
and as researchers we are relying
utilizing this data and we can get
sufficient insight from the tools and
from the project that we will be going
through and also give an opportunity to
all of you to introduce yourselves and
say a few words about why he joins and
what do you expect to get out of this
program so so he'll you want to take it
over yep sure thank you yeah hello
everyone and welcome again to the
program
my name is science 80 and I have a bad
character bioinformatics I have done my
bachelor's in bioethics from India and
my master's in bioethics play semantics
from the
Nebraska Omaha and I've been working
with pine for a year now and I mean it's
keep working with time and been
interacting quite a lot with the
participants and to previous programs I
come allies on between the participant
and between the education coordinator
and Ilia definitely so if there is any
problem any questions and issues that
come along please feel free to reach out
to me I try to be pretty responsive when
it comes to replying to the questions
and the only one thing that I would like
to request of the participants is like
you know be proactive like you know once
the session has done so I mean just take
out like a couple of hours from your
daily schedule so to us go over like
what was covered in the previous lecture
try out some pipe lines like do some
hands-on and go over the online modules
so that would give you a clearer
understanding about what happened in the
previous lecture and then what's going
to come in the next lecture so that
would help you in maintaining the peace
of the program and then that's when
you're going to benefit most out of it
and at the end definitely when there's a
chance to work on a project so you have
a better idea to people for your own
project and I would like to wish good
luck to all the participants and hope
you guys enjoy it thank you
just think
and you hear me yeah okay um so this is
Justin um I am a neurobiologist in
training I got my masters and applied
physiology and I got my PhD from
Brandeis in molecular and cellular
biology and their specialized on stem
cell differentiation in the nervous
system during development I did my
postdoc at the National Institutes of
Health I've been in academics for the
past approximately five years and more
recently I worked for a video education
company called yo which a lot of you
might have heard of so you know varied
exposure and experience as far as my
role at times as Ely mentioned
previously I think you know general
biology related questions or
biochemistry are related and how those
fields what we offer in those fields as
far as a video support and general
questions about the fields themselves
and I think more relevant I can be abuse
with respect to mapping curriculums
and integrating the content into your
current systems and I think that's one
of the limitations as faculty or
postdocs time is limited you get into
your groove things are working but I
think we also know that mixing it up
trying new things trying new approaches
to reach the students is is very
important so I like to help all of you
make that transition using our systems
make it as painless as possible and also
Julia mentioned I think one of the
important things with a support network
and using a new bioinformatics tool also
requires ongoing support right you can't
just start using using it and that's it
right you'll drip that will drop off
after a couple weeks you'll be
frustrated why did I do this so
absolutely
short-term long-term I would very much
like to help you with that process and I
find a very satisfying you know to help
fellow academics and scientists you know
Excel using our material suggested and
yeah we do have 10 minutes left here so
I do want to invite any of you if you
have any questions or you would just
like to simply introduce yourself I
think one of the major things that we've
seen in the past is that people get to
know each other they are able to
collaborate and work on some of these
practical assignments and get feedback
especially if you are in the same
location I know that we have people from
several locations and I think there's a
lot of benefit to conducting this kind
of a program online so that you can do
it from the sort of your home or your
office but at the same time you know
that interpersonal connection plays a
critical role in the success of the
overall program so if any one people
would like to say a couple of words
about you know where you are now and
maybe your position at your University
and if you have any questions we'd be
happy to answer those as well
this is a kid over here can you hear me
yeah yeah sure so I'm Aki Rajput I did
my PhD from Wiseman's unit of science
Austria and in the field of biochemistry
and molecular biology you know worked on
programmed cell death and and then then
move to San Diego Institute by the rocks
and put bones in there did research on
you became by gazes but that is when I
realized that you know lots of
biochemistry and microbiology
understanding as far as stuff is a
concern wish I was gaining it has to be
integrated by employing informatics the
land there comes the field of
bioinformatics so made a transition to
genomics-based understanding and you
know that's where I thought that
probably taking this course will really
help me to understand the basics and
implementing that to the clinical
sciences you know ultimately coming up
with some solutions which can help the
patients on the other side so that's the
motivation and I'm really looking
forward to this fantastic course and if
there are some local or people over here
in San Diego I'd be happy to join me
then otherwise even building a team and
group online or you know will be a good
good way to go so I'm really excited
about this journey for three months
thank you thank you very much
anyone else
hi I'm Laura large trader at Tulane
University can you hear me yes I am an
associate professor in some like the
biology and I'm a neuroscientist that's
been in neuroscience for probably about
30 years now and I would just like to
learn more about bioinformatics and we
have some RNA seek data that I would
like to understand how to analyze and
I'm looking forward to the course great
thank you very much
Oh
I'm Nathan I graduated with it recently
in 2017 with a degree in biology I just
had a couple of internships like your
10-week internship in a genetics lab a
wet lab and 10-week internship in
bioinformatics so I'm relatively new but
I'm very interested in helping learn a
lot through this program
thank you watching history
we know how to use it with the children
hi can you hear me people don't know I
had my footie brain biochemistry and MSC
and PhD in pharmacology and my respect
for cars must have been on genomics and
infectious diseases I'm on a postdoc at
Southern University Buttonwood so I want
to learn a lot more on by informatics
which is mostly from what my research is
based on thank you
so if you are speaking please unmute
yourself because we can't hear you
hello okay let me mix your solder from
Louisiana State University yep I'm a PhD
student at even about the program so I'm
finishing up my PhD this year and
looking for the next position and I'd
like to extend memorize into the bind
mandate much better unless I pick the
genomic data so that could be better
prepared for the next position and I'm
really excited about this program thank
you
hello okay can you hear me oh I'm
similarly I did my PhD in plant science
and currently working at the research
scientist at Bernard damper and Center
in st. Louis so my gateway research was
focused on plant beneficial microbes
interactions I'm currently working on
antimicrobial peptides and then looking
for God to learn more about RNA seek to
this course thank you
hello
apparently let me up and keep the bottle
from a meeting us it equals at the idea
hello yeah you can hear this puppet
puppet show I have done my PhD in by
informative and masterfully by
technology so my interest is angry at
analytic and physically I'm interested
in deal with social network analysis so
I try my best to learn disco Peggy
oh yeah I see that maybe are you trying
to also say something but your
microphone is muted
if your microphone is muted so we cannot
hear you
you
yeah
so I'm just introduce myself I'm dr.
Owen vitals bring from Anthony
University Kolkata I completed my PhD in
biochemistry from University of Calcutta
India and then I completed my post-op
from University of Pennsylvania with it
and at present I returned India and
working at Amity University
biotechnology Department so I prefer in
practice to understand I'll
technological aspects all these next
generation sequencing and so on so I'm
very much interested in this thank you
so much a nice to meet you
thank you
okay anyone else would like to just
briefly introduce yourself and then we
will wrap it up
okay well thank you very much everyone
for sharing with us and we will also
like I mentioned send out the survey and
please let us know as much as we would
like us to know about you and your
background as you can see there's quite
a variety of interests here people from
different types of biological problems
that calls for lower development health
related issues so we will try to make
sure that everybody gets some background
information about the different
sequencing methods for different balance
Mattox methods an idea on project
planning in consideration of those
sequencing experiment design etc factors
and then we will try to give you some
initial materials that you can either
try or as it has to mention that you are
coming with your own data or with your
own project like that's fine we would be
happy to help you get that started as
well so and you can reach out to us
directly or you can use the survey to
let us know about those types of
interests in conclusion I would just
like to say that please make sure that
you have your account set up that your
password is working that you explored
some of the technical things around on
the platform and the way that the
materials are structured and if you have
any trouble with your has before with
your email who is something not opening
let's resolve that as soon as possible
so that the next session we can dive
into the subject matter and not spend
any more time on those technical issues
at the same time I just want to say that
we will have again this upcoming
conference in Louisiana the annual
mathematics conference in Baton Rouge at
the LSU Center for computation and
technology we will have the hands-on
workshop if you are in the Baton
this area in Louisiana in general we're
welcome to join that that's going to be
a free workshop is going to be focused
on epigenetic and gene expression data
epigenomic and gene expression from
angleman syndrome and then during the
fifth and the sixth
so on the fifth in the morning we will
have that hands-on workshop you're
welcome to participate we also will have
an offline connection so this is not
listed in our schedule but if you are
failing all during that time the people
would like to join please join us we
will have Julia speaking about her
research and the lab of dr. Josef then
on Saturday on April 6th we will have
and we will send you all of this
information by email as well Saturday on
April 6th we will have several
presentations one of them will be on
different mutation patterns that can
define adaptation bio adaptation to host
and rule code also of a seminar at the
vet school that LSU you will also see
that on April 1st and 2nd we will be in
Georgetown in the Washington DC area so
April 1st we will have a workshop on
Ebola a hands-on workshop logon Bolla
this is through the systems medicine
program at Georgetown University and
then on the second we will have a
seminar on TCGA data and multi onyx
integration so we will hope to make
those sessions available as well if
you're interested you're welcome to join
that there as well any events that we
hold we will let you know and if you
would like to register and attend those
please communicate with us so that we
can set you up for those events finally
I just want to say that you know we are
very excited about this program we're
hoping that you will get a lot out of
this we will get to work together on
some datasets and you know hopefully the
thank you for joining our session is
over now and we will send you a recorded
version and a follow-up email and if
you'd like to schedule any kind of
conversations with any of our experts
here Justin - he'll end Mohit and pursue
also in around Kolkata area please let
us know thank you and good luck for the
permit